[Music]
and welcome back everybody we're staying
in Broward County Florida to finish off
the show for another new development
judge Elizabeth shurer announced this
week that she's officially leaving the
bench at the end of June now you're
right remember that sure wrote a brief
resignation letter to Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis on Wednesday expressing her
gratitude to serve the state for over a
decade and earlier in the year the judge
told members of the media that she
intended to resign after the penalty
phase of the Parkland school shooter
case in order to pursue other career
options in November a jury recommended
life in prison without parole instead of
the death penalty for the shooter who
killed 17 people at Marjory Stoneman
Douglas High School in 2018. judge sure
presided over the high profile case
which happened to be her first murder
trial she got some backlash from
Spectators and legal observers alike who
felt that she had a bias in favor of the
prosecution after the sentencing she was
seen hugging members of the prosecution
team and also members of the victims
families sure also frequently sparred
with members of the defense team
throughout the proceeding here's an
example
called for
unprofessional way to try a case
you you all knew about this and even if
you didn't make your decision until this
morning to have 22 people plus all of
this stuff and every train March into
court be waiting as if it's some kind of
game now I have to send them home the
state's not ready they're not going to
have a witness ready we have another day
wasted I I just I honestly I have never
experienced a level of unprofessionalism
in my career it's unbelievable
I have been practicing in this County
for 20. you know what I don't want to
hear it did you insulting me on the
record in front of my client and I
believe that I should be able to okay
you can do that later you can put make
your records later but you've been
insulting me the entire trial so
blatantly taking your headphones off
arguing with me
um storming out coming late
intentionally if you don't like my
rulings so quite frankly this has been
long overdue
does everyone remember that well Terry
you closely watched the sentencing
proceedings you think the Judge fairly
presided over the whole process to me I
think she showed her bias I think the
defense was correct about that we saw
just there where the defense was talking
about how in fact the judge didn't allow
them to curtail the number of witnesses
they have every right to have a witness
list and to curtail the number because
they have a strategy and the judge
really went at them there the other
issue and this is the bigger more
important issue is no question about it
the victim impact statements really
attacked the defense the defense is just
doing their job they had to advocate for
their client and I do think the way the
judge allowed those Victim Impact
statements to Target the defense
attorneys personally even talking about
their children and she didn't in any way
shape or form allow them to you know
curtail what they were doing she
definitely should have have said
something about that she didn't let the
defense argue that she'd made them
basically sit down and I also think
finally that she should not have gone up
and hugged the prosecution and hugged
the victims personally the judge is
supposed to be by unbiased and they're
supposed to just make sure that they are
fair throughout the trial and when we
see something like that it does make you
feel as though she's leaning in One
Direction and not the other well Brian
you have some pretty strong opinions on
how judge sure ended up resigning care
to share what those opinions are yeah
Justice I agree with Terry um actually
as a former public defender I don't
think this judge should be on the bench
anymore based on what Terry said and
more but my issue is the Optics of how
she was booted out my understanding was
this trial happened right and then she
was supposed to be scheduled for another
death penalty case and she was booted
out of that case it seems like because
of how the result went in the Parkland
shooter case even though she's pretty
heavily on the prosecution side so all
judges are all looking and saying hey if
I don't come down heavier on the
prosecution and the verdict doesn't come
the way it's supposed to be could I be
getting it off of cases and maybe losing
opportunities I don't like the Optics
there well I am curious to see what she
does next we will see Brian Terry thank
you both so much everyone thanks for
joining us we're going to see you next
time as we discuss Justice in America